see that didn't run you read is he's  going  she's a pro we got no movement not a  sound a doe  I'm going down there that's it  it hasn't that wall I got eyes on your  ass fancy pants oh man talk to me talk  to me what you see  something's not right  [Music]  how bad is it eyes the bullet went  through I got a man down we got a sniper  high-caliber weapon requesting  instruction you got an accent not  American your supper yes you know  where'd he come from if I were you I  would start talking Isaac what do you  want I want to get to know you I get one  shot no no no no second you touch that  write for your dead this is true but  this is over his family want to  recognize him you dehydrated  how's the same death you will bleed out  scope it's an extension of my eye you're  fading you're fading how fantastic  trigger is an extension of my best one  two feet sports path the rifle is an  extension of me what did you find when  you do the fan and I strike you down  you